hello everyone I'm Alana ochar alongside
and welcome to my channel where today I
am
so excited to get to talk to you all
about almond core 6 fires of Rubicon
oh my gosh the opening moments of this
game even though most of them are very
similar to the trailers that we've
already seen I like I feel like I was
blushing I was just so excited to be
there so today I'm going to give some of
my Impressions and mostly answer
questions from you guys I wasn't allowed
to tell people that I was playing the
game early so I couldn't put out a call
for questions like I normally do when I
get early access to a review code of a
game which huge thank you to Bandai
Namco entertainment and of course
romsoft for giving me early access to
the game so I pulled questions from
around the internet and from my previous
videos on Armored Core things that I saw
people discussing and I am going to sort
of angle this video uh to make it more
directed at people who haven't played
armored Core before because I think that
that is most of my audience first things
first just to get it out of the way this
is the best Mac game that has ever been
made it is the best Mech game to ever
exist hands down like I've played a
bunch of almond core games and I have
played a lot of Gundam games and I've
played EDF this one does is what I think
everyone else has been trying to do this
whole time it is so good at what it does
and to answer the single most common
question that I have seen people discuss
on my previous almond core videos
will you be able to play it if you've
never played any of the other games in
this series the answer is ultimately yes
you'll be fine same as any other from
soft game really the only thing that you
really have to remember that um you know
it had been a while since I'd played an
almond core game and I still picked it
up really fast the thing that makes a
Mech action game different from from
soft game or from a regular action game
are these two pillars really it is the
um multi-dimensional approach to combat
and the assembly both are super
important and very different to every
other game that you've played from
fromsoft or every other game that you've
played if you've not played a Mac game
obviously on the call not only can you
move forward backward left and right you
can also move up and down and armored
Core very quickly makes sure that you
remember to do this I don't think you'll
get past the tutorial boss if you aren't
taking advantage of the games uh
verticality you have to know when to
jump to avoid attacks that are exploding
on the ground because of course you take
a ton of Splash damage even if they
don't hit you directly and you need to
know when to go down and hide behind
something which has always been a thing
in armored Core a lot of using buildings
is cover usually when you're reloading
or just trying to avoid a specific
attack it is omnidirectional combat and
it will feel very different to really
anything you've played because of that
because you have to think about the game
as like a sphere that you are trying to
navigate again Ahmed core 65 is Rubicon
make sure you learn how to do that very
fast in that first tutorial boss and I
think it does a really great job of it
in fact especially considering it is a
from soft game I would say this game
actually is a very good tutorial I don't
know if it's just that I was picking up
with things that I was already familiar
with there are plenty of changes too
more than I actually expected it does
have more in common with Elden ring and
sakuro than I expected it to I have so
many Clips where I've been saying I'm
pretty sure this is a Mech game it's not
just Dark Souls with mechs you could
discuss that forever um it does have a
lot more in common with other from
subtitles than I thought it would which
I like but yeah if you don't use the the
space
um you'll die that's that's just the
reality of ahmedco all of the boss
fights still rely on the Dark Souls
approach which I don't like to call just
like difficulty I feel like it is
observational combat is what they do
it's not that the fights are incredibly
hard all the time not saying that they
aren't some of them are just incredibly
hard really what it's asking of you and
and the easiest way to get through any
from soft boss is for you to observe and
learn so yeah you might die a bunch of
times but it's really just because you
haven't stopped to observe and then once
you know what you're looking at and
understand how the boss is going to move
and all the patterns are you'll pick it
up it definitely has that exact same
approach to boss fights I think every
other enemy in the game is much easier
because you're a giant Mech often they
are also mechs or helicopters or drones
or whatever else but especially with the
speed of almond core 6 it is definitely
the most fluid of all of the games in
the series it is um you did such a good
job of like taking the core of armored
Core and just refining it and making it
better in a way that I just found so
goddamn delightful honestly I'm just so
happy with this game but yes it still
has that same observational combat and
that observational combat certainly
feeds very well into the omnidirectional
uh approach in a boss fight as well you
have to know phases of bosses because of
course they still have phases and when
you're going to be where on the
Battlefield the combat feels fantastic
flying in every direction it's so easy
to control as long as you're paying
attention to your HUD because your heart
is super important like you need to know
exactly how many bullets you have left
at pretty much any given time because if
you run out and you're trying to spam
your right trigger you're just gonna end
up getting smoked but all of the
information you need at all times is on
screen in a way that I just feel like
they perfected the HUD honestly it's so
good about giving you the exact
information that you need in an
aesthetic that suits the game and is
appealing like just nailed that so the
other thing of course um where a Met
game is concerned is assembly and
addressing how you want your Mac to play
um including the option of course to
make different builds for different
levels this is also a thing that I think
is very important to know about armored
Core 6 armored Core in general you can
play through the game once in um 15
hours or so that is one playthrough but
that's not really the point of the game
when you unlock new game plus and you go
through New Game Plus you'll unlock a
whole bunch of extra stuff so saying
that like start to credits is 15 hours
technically correct that is not an
accurate representation of how you are
expected to play this game the point is
much more about replaying missions in
order to get the s-rank to get the
highest rank possible uh and as you do
that and you unlock more things again
new game plus you will then unlock more
content the game will shift around you
essentially but a lot of that is you
trying to uh make sure that you earn
money and unlock parts for your Mac so
that you can customize them and then you
know you play through with your new
custom built Mech and realize that you
need a different set of legs to get
through the level so it is ever changing
and thankfully they make it very easy to
swap around Mech pods it's something I
really appreciate is like if you buy
something you can sell it for the same
value so if you didn't like something
you just resell it and you don't lose
money for it and I do think it's
especially important here because the
biggest criticism that I have around
McCall which has been a criticism that
I've had of virtually every Met game is
that a lot of the levels are repetitive
you are often doing the same thing you
drop in you go to a waypoint you shoot
other mechs next Waypoint shoot other
Max next Waypoint shoot other mix that
is still certainly a thing that exists
in Almond core that if you don't like
that in Mac games you will not like here
again they do a fantastic job of taking
that formula and making it interesting
though uh with the amount of
customization how personalized the
customization feels I'd be very
surprised if people have similar builds
though it is very easy for you to
probably if you want to and you don't
want to get super into like custom
making an exact kind of build to just go
and pick whichever one gives you blue
arrow up and less red arrow down and
just figure it out that way but there is
a ton of variety which is like I feel
like I'm going on so many tangents on
myself in this video but there's so much
to say this game does do something
really well that I think a lot of RPGs
really mess up not that it's an RPG but
it's the RPG element of it in that you
can get new parts and they aren't just
like objectively better my thing is
always like why is it there if I don't
have to think about it it's just like
adding more busy work in Ahmed cool
there's always a bit more decision
making that you have to be conscious of
your weight you have to be conscious of
traversal and there will be just as many
down arrows as up hours a lot of the
time but yeah you have your weapons your
inner parts and your frame parts and
different parts essentially change the
strategy of the game they change how you
have to approach levels which is the
thing that keeps the levels feeling
fresh and they do a great job of that
and you will decide to use different ACS
for different missions that will happen
it is not um likely that many people at
all we'll just go through the whole game
with one AC by choice I can't really see
that happening there are some levels
that are much easier with certain leg
builds than others and that's one of my
favorite things about it too is like
even as you're going through these
levels and completing them you'll
probably in your head even if you finish
the level be like like you know what
should have had a more tanky build for
that one because of the enemies I'm
seeing here this kind of build would be
more appropriate let me change that when
I finish it and go back in and try it
that way so you're just like always
thinking about the way that you can
improve your build in a way that like I
think that was probably the most
addictive thing about the game which is
great because that is the core of the
mech game and I think they've done a
fantastic job of balancing the
importance of things like the correct
kind of legs are just as important as
the correct kind of weapons so if you've
got your builds done and you've got your
omnidirectional awareness sorted
and you've got your observational combat
down this is where uh armed core
introduces something that is very
similar to Sakura which is actually my
favorite from soft game there is a
stagger system that is basically one to
one the same as Sakura's Paris system in
armid core 6 they call it instability I
believe and when your target has full
instability it'll be like a little bar
above their head and once they've filled
out their instability they lose stance
and you can go in with some really heavy
hits again similar to Sakura's like
death blows they are literally just
staggered usually just standing still
especially in the case of the bosses and
you just go in and you beat the hell out
of them that's usually uh the most
common time that I was pulling out my
melee or my Close Quarters combat you
can also be staggered and it sucks
you'll probably die but at least this
time around Almond core does give you
the ability to heal which is nice you
have three backpacks but the Stagger
stuff was just as important in any of
the boss fights here as I feel like it
was in Sakura and I really like that
approach that Bob will go down if
they're hitting you goes up as you're
hitting them really makes you constantly
have to think about where you're going
to position yourself to be most
effective in combat dude I love this
game like talking about sitting here and
talking about it it does so many things
so well
um that other Mech games uh I don't know
I have no idea if people are going to
share my sentiments on this but I really
do think it is the best in the in the
genre but yeah then you also have to
consider you can have four weapons
equipped at once and which you're using
at which time and again paying attention
to that HUD making sure that you have
the right uh amount of ammo or that
you're recharged and which of the many
inputs in the game you want to be doing
at the same time the biggest tip that I
would give if anyone's like how do I get
through this just constantly be moving
in all directions at all times if you're
new to armored Core just move all the
time but you know you might be thinking
about firing missiles and shooting a
handgun and boosting and strafing all at
the same time and somehow it never feels
overwhelming but yeah otherwise a lot of
the game is about collecting logs and
trying to get that that S rank that's
really the goal if someone here said I
wonder if you can play missions out of
order yes you can you get uh job offers
from different clients essentially and
you can approach some of those in
whatever order you like often you'll
approach it based on what the rewards
are different amounts of money for
different jobs and you will occasionally
come across certain missions that say
decision the decision missions are
pretty cool so you may have like two
separate clients who have opposing goals
because you are a mercenary that's what
you're doing Merc stuff and as soon as
you complete one of those missions the
other missions that were available will
become unavailable so in order to like
actually fully complete the game you do
need to play through it multiple times
and make different decisions in those
missions to be able to play different
missions so this is a comment about
um the music sounding very good and yes
I will say loved the music it's so much
fun it's so cool very like synthy
dramatic totally sort of like a lot of
depth to it I'm like especially cool
when some of the Boss Designs are just
so weird and creative they always are in
front of games but when you add like the
mech Flair to it I feel like it's extra
weird for some reason like somebody had
to build it like it's not like like
Margaret who just exists you know like
somebody had to build that thing I feel
like that changes how I see it but yeah
music awesome visual Fidelity awesome
they've done so much with the depth and
verticality of these levels that I
absolutely love like I often would just
stop and just like stare into the
distance even though I'm aware I can't
go certain places if you try to go out
of bounds you'll just like hit a red
barrier which did sometimes annoy me a
little during boss fights I did also
have um like a couple of like minor AI
issues or something where our boss would
occasionally clip on the side of a level
and I would not be able to get to them
like they got stuck that happened to me
twice but like I couldn't get to them
because they were technically out of
bounds but yes the environments are
stunning the only thing that I think
they haven't done there which I've not
seen any Mech game do successfully
unfortunately is uh
the scale still feels a little off they
just always do for some reason except
like when you're going off one of the
catapults which are awesome and very
similar to uh Elder ring funnily enough
you still just feel like you're a normal
sized thing in a normal sized Arena
rather than feeling like a giant Mech
and I just feel like I've had that
experience with every Mech game there
are moments where that's not true but
for the most part it doesn't make you
feel big is this going to be as hard as
dark souls and Elder ring I feel like
I've mostly already covered that
um but I will say
overall no there are two bosses that uh
I think stand out as being exceptionally
difficult you'll know when you get there
you'll know who I'm referring to but
otherwise I find it to be a little
easier but but not in any negative way
you still like all of the positives I
previously previously mentioned clearly
apply or it's super thought provoking
and you still have to have a lot of
awareness you just kind of have a few
more options and I think that that makes
it a little bit easier I did find it
easier overall one thing that's a little
bit of a bummer is like the the game
does have a ton of checkpoints which not
all amid core games have had some before
boss fights and uh in order to like
change your build and buy stuff you
might have to restart the whole level
that is one thing that I would
definitely change are there going to be
multiple endings there are multiple
endings yes and like I said a lot of
replayability again even feels weird to
say that it is a game that you have to
play multiple times and that is pretty
much all of the questions that I have in
front of me here um I also didn't want
to go too deep into stuff because I
didn't want to spoil anything like I
said I think this is the best Mech
action game ever made they did a
fantastic job I was so happy to get to
play it really really really enjoyed it
um there are some great story moments
like really fun ones some incredibly
cool and definitely very frustrating
fights it is a lot of fun and I'm really
hoping that a bunch of people who've
never tried this genre before get into
it um just note that everything else
pales in comparison